grab your surgical tools and clean your
bathwater because it's episode one of
George RR Martin's night fliers and this
one is extra crispy now before I get
started I wanted to say I haven't read
the novella this miniseries is based on
so all my theories and observations
could be totally wrong for those of you
have read it so feel free to laugh at me
and tell me how far off I am sit back
relax and enjoy this trip to Valle Chron
as we uncover the secrets of night
fliers we open on wait are those trees
yes
trees and space and as well later learn
this entire opening scene takes some
time in the future and those trees are
likely from the dome which supplies
oxygen to the ship then we meet dr.
Agatha Matheson where things aren't
going so well the ship has lost gravity
and she's covered in blood she heads
into the med bay and you can tell by the
floating pills in this machine here
which is commonly used for blood tests a
mysterious bloody hand turns the gravity
back on as Agatha forms the recorder
she's picked up that the night flyer has
sustained heavy damage and multiple
fatalities even more concerning is that
she refers to this message not as a
distress call rather a warning stating
do not bring the night flyer back to
earth she puts the recorder in the bio
waste disposal before she's attacked
jack torn style by a man will come to
know as Rowan the crews xenobiologist
but she's able to fend him off jamming
in the leg with what appears to be a
meat thermometer check out the weird
pieces of meat here too she's able to
jettison the recorder into space before
taking a surgical saw in slitting her
own throat I wouldn't expect anything
less from Georgia or Martin you can make
out on the side of the ship the word
eros which is the name of the company
that made the ship and also the name of
the captain we'll get into that in a bit
on earth a man named Karl de Brannon is
asked if he has any sickness or sores
and is cleared for entry whatever state
the earth is in it looks like some sort
of disease or infection has taken it
over his wife joy is watching the news
which shows a sealeo outbreak a
fictitious and deadly disease which
seems to be the culprit Carl tells joy
that he got a call from the leader of
the night flyer he wants to assemble a
team to go after the Volk Ron a
mysterious alien ship earth has been
unable to communicate with he
a mission that could potentially save
the earth but it would mean he'd be away
from his wife and daughter for at least
two years
Karl explains to his daughter sky that
he's gonna talk with these aliens and
she gives him a friendship bracelet to
remember her before his memory is
interrupted and we find out were
actually six months in the future in the
year 20 93 on a shuttle dock at the
night flyer colony on this shuttle we
meet melanthius mission specialist and
this skittish woman lomi thorn the
engineer in charge of internal systems
data flow and coding she has a neural
port that allows her to connect to ship
systems and control them automatically
Mel explains their going into the void a
dark and dangerous uncharted part of
space where the Voltron is were also
reintroduced to Agatha who we learn as a
psychologist responsible for sail sail
is an l1 Carl explains that el ones are
telepaths who emit the same type of
energy as that of the Valle cron since
all other ways of communicating with it
have failed perhaps an l1 like fail is
the key
Agatha explains she's known fail since
they were kids and judging by the
security and huge metal container he's
in his powers are quite substantial so
this big dude here goes for a little
sneak peek since he thinks the l1 is
waking up and his mind is suddenly
infiltrated by him depicting him in
front of this space like image but
really what it looks like is an eye like
someone being able to see into his soul
Agatha calls this psychic feedback
claiming it's harmless carl shows agatha
the dome where plants and crops are
grown in space he was able to make a
deal so fail can spend two hours a week
down there a mighty improvement over
what fail has gone through living his
entire life without sunshine or fresh
air and look who it is it's rolling the
xenobiologist / ax man yes the same axe
wielding murderer from the intro who
ironically shakes hands with the woman
he will later try to kill she tells him
he must be thrilled to be making first
contact with alien life but Rowan is
skeptical what's out there is likely far
scarier than what they can imagine at
dinner we learned Carl has never
actually seen captain eros when Mel
asked if it's true he's never come out
of his cabin this important detail is
glossed over until they're interrupted
by Murphy who is not pleased in l1 has
been brought on board
no wonder they had guns pointed at
they'll when he came out
apparently ell ones are murderers and
were responsible for some sort of
massacre on Luna 71 Lunas 71 most likely
a colony on the moon where something
very very bad happened fail although
unwanted still might be the only thing
that can communicate with a vole Kron
which may unlock the powers to save
their dying earth Agustin captain
Harris's second-in-command however
informs everyone that if they wish to
leave the colony they may likely an
order passed on by the captain who's
watching via how jr. over here and we
get to meet him in the next scene where
he gives a big speech about how this
mission could change the course of
humanity yet he only arrives via a
projection leading me to believe he's
not real at all just an AI created by
Aris Corp but soon into their flight the
engines malfunction and Murphy saves the
day only to be viciously tossed by
gravity in the loading bay these two
thugs wonder if it was failed the l1 who
somehow messed up the thrusters one of
the thugs [ __ ] his gun and sees himself
hanging but it's all fails power who can
make people see things not to mention
read their minds Carl and Agatha
explained failed doesn't have the
ability to alter the engine of the ship
he can access people's minds but not the
data of the ship for example if Agatha
could talk to him for some more
information they may find some clues as
to what actually happened
Agatha takes out a tranquilizer and
confronts they´ll but he knows she just
wants to find out if he was the one
responsible for the thruster malfunction
in the corridors carl was haunted by the
sound of a child's voice potentially his
child who we saw earlier and since
they'll isn't tranquilized yet and his
cell is open it could be him who's
making Carl heared these things
Agatha then puts they'll under and sorts
through some of his drawings look at
this one here of a skull which we'll get
a better look of later
lomi has used her neural port to gain
access to the ship's data but can't find
the source of the malfunction but even
more concerning is that she's picked up
that the Volk ron has shifted course
making it an additional five months off
target and deeper into the void carl
talks to his wife about the problems on
the ship and we learned that their
daughter has indeed passed away some
time ago I also got a weird vibe when he
brings up Agatha that there may be some
history between
on her we don't really know yet then the
connection breaks up and we get this
really weird distorted skull face which
makes me think of that drawing of fails
is it him controlling it but I thought
he is tranquilized is it just a bad
connection or is it something more
sinister in the halls of the ship Carl
seems to be haunted by his daughter and
a creepy red coat as the windows of the
ship freeze up now this would have to be
a dream or vision since windows and
space wouldn't freeze up like this in
Agatha's cabin she goes over Thales
drawings and we get a better look at the
skull drawing which reminds me a lot of
HR Giger I hope I'm pronouncing that
right anyways he did a lot of the
artwork for alien even creepier is his
drawing of Agatha and the shower here
Carla rise asking if she got anything
from sale and he finds the drawings even
one of his daughter Agatha says those
drawings are what other people in the
ship are seen Carl tells her sales
making him see things but Agatha says
Elle ones under suppression can't do
that mal comes back from a run only to
be perved by captain Eris who explains
he's never had a genetically modified
human on board
thus he finds her fascinating she's been
genetically designed to best adapt for
space travel we also learned that Eris
has never been to earth once again
another hint that he's not human
but even more damning is him wanting to
get a glimpse of someone's soul and of
course an AI or program would want to
know more about that since they can
never have a soul
Carl visits Rowan unsure that Agatha can
properly handle Thale for their eventual
meeting with the Volk ron and rowan
makes a good point here they've tried
every means of communication but the
Volk ron just won't respond how is an
unruly childish empath going to be the
best first step forward in contacting an
alien civilization that could wipe them
all out even goes so far as to call
humans a virus that have killed their
host earth and are now desperately
looking for a new one Mel takes one of
those futuristic showers like an Empire
Strikes Back when the tank malfunctions
she even sees a vision of her own head
floating in the tank next to hers lomi
being logged into the system is able to
see the malfunction and rushes to save
her what I find even creepier than fails
seemingly controlling this situation is
captain Eris watching it unfold and
doing nothing there's a lot going on
here we've yet to discover under the
dome
they´ll has his first session among the
plants and soil he tells Agatha that
he's not responsible for putting
thoughts into Carl's head which either
means he's lying or there could possibly
be another l1 on board or maybe even
something else Carl wants to bring him
to see captain Harrison sets up a
perimeter around fail sensing he may be
put to sleep permanently fail retaliates
incapacitating the guards and making
them spontaneously vomit but before he
can do any more damage he's shot in the
neck with a tranquilizer dart I can feel
it like it's right in my neck when Thale
awakens highly sedated he tells captain
Harris he can't feel his thoughts
obviously because he's a projection eros
demands that for the safety of the ship
they'll be put off line so he can run
Diagnostics and Agatha complies lomi
comes to check up on Malin they discuss
whether they'll could have controlled lo
mismo and she had access to the ship and
then they discuss some other stuff Carl
goes back to the memory room to see her
daughter blowing a daffodil in her red
coat just like in fails drawing he has
to stop the memory playback but it
malfunctions and yes malfunctioning
seems to be a very recurring theme here
and he's haunted by memories of her
daughter which he says that's not how it
happened finally he manages to escape
just as his daughter's elongated hand
reaches out for him
Carl confronts Agatha claiming she
didn't properly medicate him he'll need
to see for himself that vales been
properly sedated they go to his cell but
someone has sprung him loose now it's
possible it could be Agatha who did it
but we're just not certain yet captain
Harris arrives moments later and when
they ask to check the security cameras
apparently someone has breached the
system and all of them went dark Carl
and the team decide they need to find
Dale before the captain's men do or it's
gonna be a bloodbath for everyone on
board Mel even smashes the VidCon so the
captain can't listen in
Lumi hooks herself up and were
reintroduced to Murphy who's been
instructed to get the cameras back
online
Lumi malfunctions another malfunction
while navigating the ship neuropathic
aliy and there's nothing anyone else can
do because taking her out of that state
would imprison her in there then she
does her best audition for get out
Oh before awakening and rushing away
down in the pipes Murphy tries to fix
the problem when he's confronted by fail
who turns his gun into a bleeding heart
Rouen finds the system going into fire
wall breach mode as the camera male
smash turns dark red ominously similar
to how in 2001 a Space Odyssey
Murphy's been charred to bits seriously
that guy has not had a good day as the
crew continues their search and the
night flyer carries on to the vast
expanse of space so this episode leaves
a ton of unanswered questions is it fail
really controlling all of these visions
or is something else at play here
who is captain Eris and are his
intentions good and of course what will
happen when they eventually reach the
Voltron in a December we're not much is
coming out this may be a good show to
pass the time so let me know if you want
me to keep doing breakdowns or if you
just want me to do one final ending
explain video love to hear your theories
and thoughts below and until next time
daddy loves you very much